[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشيخ
في الوقت الذي احدثكم
وتتفاعلوا هذه الصور تاتيكم مباشره
التي تصدر منها الدعوات مجددا لدعملها
بالسلاح والحديد تحديدا عن دبابات لترد
الالمانيه
ومن كاليفورنيا الامريكيه المزيد من
المؤتمرات المرتقبه للسلطات هناك بعد هجوم
اسفل عن مقتل 10 اشخاص في لص عن جنس
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
في اتساع لاجابهات التصعيد في جنوب وشرق
اوكرانيا اشتداد المعارك في باخموت وموسكو
تقول ان قوتها سيطرت على مواقع في
زمولوجيا ومع تهديد روسيا برد الانتقاميا
على تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه هجوميه ماكرون
يقول ان ارساله دبابات الفرنسيه امر غير
مستبعد واشنطن تمدد مهمه الالاف من قوتها
في رومانيا
بعد اقالته تنفيذا لقرار المحكمه العليا
نتنه يتعهد لزعيم حركه شاس بايجاد سبيل
لعودته الى الحكومه وللاسبوع الثالث
مظاهرات ضد سعي الحكومي لسن قانون يتيح
للاغلبيه البرلمانيه الغاء قرارات المحاكم
ومن مقعد المعارضه لابيد يصف حكومه
نتنياهو بحلبه السرك
بوركينا فاسو تمهل فرنسا شهرا لسحب جميع
قواتها وتربط القرار باحتجاجات شعبيه
اتهمت باريس في مواجهته هجمات الارهابيه
هو مصادر حكوميه تقول ان القرار غير مرتبط
باتفاقيه التعاون الامني وليس قطعا
العلاقه دبلوماسيه والرئيس الفرنسي يلمح
لدور الروسي ويكون انه ينتظر توضيحات من
السلطه العسكريه الحاكمه في وجده
مع احترامي المعارك بين القوات السومريه
وحركه الشباب هجوم للحركه على بلديه
العاصمه مقديشو السلطات تعلن سيطره على
الوضع والقضاء على المهاجرين وتقول ان
الهجوم اسفر عن مقتل خمسه مدني
وفي لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا طلب بوركينا فاسو من فرنسا
رسميا سحب قواتها من البلاد بدون شهر
مظاهرات ونستمرت لاشهر حيث اتهم
المتظاهرون فرنسا بعدم القيام بما يكفي
لمساعده البلاد في مواجهه الهجمات
الارهابيه
بالتواطئ في بعض الاحياء وقد سبق قرار
وكنا فاسو اخر مماثل من مالي ما اعطى
الامر بعدا اوسع يتعلق بالنفوذ الدوليه
هناك تذكر فيه روسيا
الاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
طرحنا عليكم السؤال الثالث في اي شيء ياتي
طلب بكينا فاسو مغادره القوات الفرنسيه
30 في المئه قالوا ان هذا الطلب يعود الى
ملفات ثنائيه داخليه بينما صوت 70 في
المئه لصالح خيار دخول روسيا على خط
المنافسه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم الدخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصه الرقم يتجدد يوميا
ونتظر خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
شو تتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
الخان الاحمر قصه معاناه تتصاعد بحضور
حكومه اليمين الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا
ضخمه المشهد خلال الايام الماضيه
الاعلانات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه السيطره
على مواقع
بالنفي وقالت ان الحديث الروسي عن اختراق
دفاعات جيشها هناك ادعاء مزيف مشيره الى
ان الجيش الاوكراني استعاد جميع مواقع
سيطرته خلال ساعات الماضيه وقد نفعت القوه
الروسيه الى موقعها السابقه في ذا الوجه
وقفت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه صورا قالت
انها لقصف قواتها مواقع روسيه في المقاطعه
الجنوبيه البلاد وقالت الهيئه ان القصف
الدائره مقتل 30 جنديا روسيا وان قواتها
تواصل استهداف العتاد الروسي ومواقع تمركز
الافراد في زمرجيا
وكان المتحدث باسم القوات الاوكرانيه في
مقاطعتي زفر وجيه وخيرسون
اكد التصاعد العمليات القتاليه في مقاطعه
الزفه جنوبيه البلاد وضيفا ان القوات
الروسيه تحشد قواتها باتجاه خيرسون كما
ترسل المزيد من التعزيزات عبر شبه جزيره
القرن
وبالحديث عن خيرس والمعارك المحتدمه فيها
تبع مراسنا تامر الصمادي الذي وصل الى
احدى اقرب نقاط بين الطرفين تمام
المدفعيه الاوكرانيه حاضره هنا على الدواء
ندخل الى احدى نقاط الاشتباك السريه للجيش
الاوكراني يقول الاوكرانيون ان جبهه
الجنوب تميل لصالحهم نقف الان عند اقرب
خطوط المواجهه بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه هذه واحده من الدبابات
الاوكرانيه التي سمح لنا بتصويرها وهي
تتهيا في هذه اللحظه للاطلاق باتجاه
القوات الروسيه
غير بعيد يستعد جنود مدفعيه لاطلاق قذائف
جديده تتوارى المدافع الاوكرانيه خلف
اغصان الاشجار تحسبا من عدو غير مرئي
قائد الفريق يتاكدوا من كل خطوه فعلى
الجبهه لا مجالا للخطا
هناك على الضفه المقابله في هذه اللحظه
يتم ارسال موقعهم الينا بدقه عبر اللاسلكي
وانتظار الامر باستهدافهم
حانت لحظه الاطلاق
[تصفيق]
قديفه اخرى يهتز المكان من قوتها
يقول الجيش الاوكراني ان هذه الصور تظهر
قصفه نقاط الروسيه في مكان اخر ترابط
مدفعيتها وتزر الامريكيه في اطار الدعم
العسكري الذي تقدمه واشنطن تركيا
على ضفه الشرقيه
بقصف المدينه والمواقع السكنيه والبنيه
التحتيه
تتوسع دائره الحرب فالقصف الروسي على مركز
المدينه لا يتوقف عشرات الالاف فروا وبقي
اخرون اما احلامهم بان تضع الحرب واوزارها
قريبا فذهبت ادراج الريح
سيطر الروس على مقاطعه هيرسون في بدايه
الحرب قبل ان يستعيد الاوكرانيون مدينتها
اواخر العام الماضي لينسحب الروس الى
الضفه الشرقيه من نهر النيبر التي تشكل
قرابه نصف المقاطعه ولخير سون اهميتها بدا
من موقعها على البحر الاسود وبحر ازوف
وليس انتهاء بارتباطها بشبه جزيره القرقه
تامر حسني
ولمناقشه ما يجري في اوكرانيا بشكل عام في
خير سنه تحديدا معنى من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
بك فايز
في الواقع يعني الوضع نوعا ما غريب يعني
القوات الروسيه تترك خيرسون ثم تستمر في
قصفها بشكل مكثف حتى اليوم يحاول ان نفهم
يعني الغرض العسكري لهذا التصرف
يعني اولا هو ااه الانسحاب كان انسحاب
الضروره
وكانت القوات الروسيه يمكن ان تطوق
وبالتاليع القائد الميداني اييه
كان قراره سحب القوه بناء خطه دفاعيه وخط
دفاعي قوي
وبالتالي استخدام فائض القوه في الاماكن
الاخرى التي تحتاجها
وابقاء الجبهه مشتعله
لاجبار الجانب الاوكراني على ابقاء مزيد
من قواته في تلك المنطقه اذا هو حقق اكثر
من هدف انه انقذ قواته من خطر التطويق
والمحاصره استغل هذه القوات في مناطق اخرى
وابقى الجبهه
مشتعله من خلال القصف المدعي والصاروخي
وهذا كثيرا ما حدث في مسرح المسرح الروسي
في الحرب العالميه اثناء الغزو الالماني
لهم طيب هو في النهايه يعني هذا القصف
المستمر ووجود الزفاروجا
خيرسون في قلب المشهد الى اي حد مرتبط
ايضا التي تصدرت المشهد خلال الفتره
الماضيه ايضا
يعني الان هناك ثلاثه مناطق ساخنه
المنطقه الاولى تقع في اقصى الشمال
في منطقه اكريمينا والقوات الروسيه هي
التي تهاجم والقوات الاوكرانيه في موقف
الدفاع والرئيس الاوكراني وسفر الوضع بانه
صعب
المقترب الاخر سوليدر باخمود وهذا من
مسؤوليه قوات باجنر بصوره رئيسيه باسناد
الجيش الروسي تم فتح جبهه جديده في منطقه
جبروجها تم السيطره كما قيل على بعض
البلدات واختراق سبعه كيلو سبعه كيلو
مترات ولكن الجانب الاوكراني نفذ ذلك
وبالتالي هو نوع من توسيع دائره او خط
المواجهه لاجبار القوات الاخرانيه على
تشتيت جودها ووضع الاحتياط
العملياته والاستراتيجي في موقع او في
موقف مربك الان الحديث عن محاوله حشد
القوه اا في خرسون وبالتالي هذا سيضع
املاءات وتحديدات جديده على الجانب
الاوكراني عليه ان يقيم حجم هذه القوات
نوع هذه القوات ومن خال خلال الحجم والنوع
يستطيع ان يحدد ما هي الاهداف المستقبليه
هل هي محاوله
لجنه هجوم اني ام هل هي تحضير لهجوم
الربيع هل هي لعبور النهر ام هل يعني هناك
تطرح العديد من التساؤلات تجيب عليها
المنظومات الاستخباريه التي تركب كل حركه
لكن هي في النهايه خط الجبهه اكثر من 1000
كيلو متر اذا ما تم اشغاله بصوره كبيره
سيضع اضافي على القوات الاوكرانيه
على موضوع الدبابات بدليل انه لا يترك
مناسبه الا ويصر على ضروره تزويد اوكرانيا
في هذه المرحله هل الدبابات ستحدث هذا
الفارق على الارض الذي يريده الرئيس
يعني هل تحذف فريق نعم لكن ما هو حجم هذا
الفارق وهذا التاثير هذا مرتبط بالاعداد
التي سيتم ارسالها الحديث عن 14 دبابه
تشالنجر هي عباره عن سريع سريع الدبابات
وبالتالي هي اصغر وحده وحده دروع مقاتله
بصوره مستقله لن تقدم الكثير الان كان
هناك خبر عاجل ان يعطي شيء من الانفراجه
ان المانيا لا تمانع همم ان ترسل بولندا
دبابات اليو بارك وبالتالي هذا يعتمد على
حجم هذه الدبابات لكن السؤال متى يتم
اعداد الاطقم المدربه بفاعليه وما هي
الاعداد التي سيتم ارسالها هناك 14 دبابه
هنا في الجانب
البولندي كم سيتم ارسال يفترض يعني
الاستخدام الامثل له هذا لهذا النوع من
السلاح هو مجموعه الواجب او التاسك فورس
وهذه اعداد الدبابات فيها بالحد الادنى 35
وبالحد الاعلى 55 دبابه اذا اذا وصل هذا
العدد نعم ستقدس ستشكل اضافه نوعيه وستقدم
خدمات جيده في البعدين الدفاع والوجومي لك
من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري
في اخر التطورات بشان دبابات الالمانيه
وجدل منحها لاوكرانيا كما اشار اللواء
فايز قبل قليل كانت وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه قالت ان برلين لم تعارض ارسال
بولندا لهذه الدبابات اذا ما قررت وارث
ذلك وكان المتحدث باسم الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه
ستتلقى دبابات لبرد اثنين وانا المفاوضات
جاريه حاليا بهذا الشان
وبعد لفت قال الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل
ماكرون اليوم انه لا يستبعد تسليم دبابات
من طراز الكلير القتاليه الثقيله
لاوكرانيا حديثا متزايد عن مساعده باسلحه
قتاليه ترد عليه موسكو بالتحذير والتهديد
اذ قال رئيس مجلس الدومه الروسيه
عفوا ان الامر سيؤدي الى كارثه عالميه
وحذر من ان هذا التوجه سيقود الى اجراءات
انتقاميه باسلحه اقوى على حد تعبيره
امريكيا انقل الفنطقون انه
اييي انه قد يمدد مهمه عده الاف من قواتها
في جنوب شرق رومانيا سيمددها بالاحرار
لمده تسعه اشهر اخرى على الاقل تنفيذا
الالتزام الرئيس بيدن بتعزيز الوجود
الامريكي في اوروبا في اعقاب الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا واعتبر الفنتجه من
ان هذه الخطوه ستتضمن استمرار الوضع الجيد
للولايات المتحده
لتوفير موقفا رادعا قويا ودفاعيا الى جانب
حلفائها في اوروبا
وقد سرعت حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا من وتيره
الانتشار العسكري الامريكي وعديد القوات
الامريكيه في ما يعرف بالجبهه الشرقيه
الان ابرز ملامح هذا الانتشار في دول
اوروبا المختلفه خصوصا الغربيه والقريبه
جغرافيه من روسيا في هذا العرض
تنشروا الولايات المتحده قوتها في مختلف
دول اوروبا خصوصا ما تعرف بالجبهه الشرقيه
نحو 80 الف جندي قبل الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا تجاوز حاليا مئه الف جندي مع
سياده واشنطن قوتها ردا على الحرب الروسيه
من بين ما تنشره الولايات المتحده في
المانيا
لوحده لدفاع الجوي وكتيبه لدعم القتاليه
ويبلغ عدد جنودها هناك نحو ثمانيه و
30,000 وفق تقارير مختلفه في الجبهه
الشرقيه للحلف وتحديدا بولندا تنشر
الولايات المتحده بشكل دائم مركز قياده
متقدمه لمقر قياده لواء الخامس في الجيش
الامريكي
عدد جنودها 10,000 و500 جندي اما في
رومانيا فتنشر الولايات المتحده بصفه
تناوبيه سريعه قتاليه في قاعده ميخائيل
الجويه التي تتخذ مركز لتدريب قوه ويبلغ
عدد افرادها نحو اربعه الاف جنديه امريكيه
وفي دول البلطيق عززت واشنطن النشره
التنوبيه لقوتها المؤلفه من قوه مدرعه
وطائرات وانظمه دفاع جوي وقوه خاصه
واجمالا تجاوز عدد جنودها في الدول
الثلاثه 2500 جندي وفي ايطاليا للولايات
المتحده نحو احد عشر الفا وخمس مئه من
جنودها وتنشر بطاريه لدفاع الجوي قصير
المدى اما في اسبانيا فكانت واشنطن قررت
رفع عدد المدنرات من اربعه الى سته ويوجد
باسبانيا نحو الفي جندي امريكي وفي
المملكه المتحده تنشر الولايات المتحده
سردين من مقاتلات
35,000 من الجيل الخامس في قاعده لايك
نيتل الجويه ويوجد في بريطانيا نحو احد
عشر الف جندي امريكي
[موسيقى]
بيع عناوين عديده التقى كل من الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون والمستشار
الالماني
المشترك بعد القمه اكد على استمرار دعم
اوكرانيا مهما طالت الحرب كما اشار البيان
الى وجود حاجه ملحه لتسريع انضمام دول غرب
البلقان الى الاتحاد الاوروبي قد اكد
الرئيس الفرنسي في مؤتمر بعد اللقاء على
ضروره عمل بلاده والمانيا على ان تصبح في
رياده اعاده تاسيس اوروبا
وينضم الينا من برلين
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه ستانفورد
في برنامج اهلا وسهلا
في قراءتك انت ما هي ما هو السياق الذي
تاتي فيه هذه القمه
[موسيقى]
هذه القمه ستكون حدثا مهما لفرنسا
وللمانيا للتعبير عن خاصيه واهميه العلاقه
التي تجمع البلدين في ضمن الاتحاد
الاوروبي واذا ما وضعناها في سياق تاريخي
هذا تغير ثوريد العلاقه بين الدولتين
الذين قبل الاف السنوات قتلها بعضهما
البعض وبعد ذلك مع بعضهما البعض من اجل
بناء المستقبل ومنذ ذلك الوقت
كان هنالك مواقف قد يكون فيها مواقف
اختلاف بين البلدين ولكن الان الرئيس
ماكرون يتحدث على ضروره ان يتخذ البلدان
دورا قياديا وري يعني في تاسيس اوروبا ما
هي اوروبا التي يريدها ويتحدث عنها مكروم
برايك
رؤيا هو لديه افكار رائعه ويقدمها بخطاب
فصيح في السوربون حيث تحدث المستشار ايضا
هي اهم الجامعات ايضا
وهذا يختلفون
الالمانيه الذي يفضل ان ياخذ خطوات بشكل
تدريجي اذا مقاربتهما مختلفه في مساله دمج
اوروبا والامر يجعل من الصعب توافق على
الخطوات المهمه مثلا الذي يجب ان يكون
النظام المستقبلي السياسي وكيف نقوم
بالتعامل مع قضايا مثل المناخ وكيف ندير
مثلا التحول الرقمي ايضا لدينا مجتمعات
همم كبيره في السن لذلك هنالك الكثير من
القضايا في فرنسا وفي المانيا تحتاج الى
الاصلاح على المستوى الاتحاد الاوروبي
والدينا ايضا الكثير من الخلافات فيما
يتعلقوا في دول همم في وسطي اوروبا
بالتالي هنالك حاجه ماسه الى الاصلاح لكن
بدون المانيا وفرنسا الامر لن يحدث
تحدثت عن توتر بين البلدين ولكن هذه القمه
وما تدعو اليه هل سنرى نتائجها في ملفات
معينه مثلا الدفاع الاوروبي المشترك
الطاقه ما هي اهم الملفات التي سنشهد فيها
شيء من التغيير وما هي ملفات التي تبقى
اكثر تحديا هنا
ماكرون
انما هو اهم ان كلا الدولتين لديهما اراده
قويه من اجل التوصل الى نقاط اتفاق والبدء
بعمليه اصلاح الاتحاد الاوروبي لكننا
ناتي من خلفيات ثقافيه مختلفه ولدينا
اولويات مختلفه بالتالي الاراء حول هذه
الاوروبا المستقبليه تختلف بالاضافه الى
المصالح الوطنيه لكل بلد بالتالي
الانجازات المهمه هو تعتمد على بناء
هيكليه المؤسسات ضمن الاتحاد الاوروبي
التي تقوم
من اجل التجاوز الخلافات من اجل ان تحتفظ
بالمانيا كالمانيا
فرنسا بالتالي من الصعب ان نقول اننا قد
نجد نقاط مشتركه في ملف معه ولكن نختلف في
ملفات اخرى لكن هذه الاليه الاليه
الموجوده التواصل والتقديم التنازلات ما
تزال موجوده
استاذه العلوم السياسيه في جامعه ستاند
فورد من برلين شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اقل رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو زعيمه حركه شاس وزير الداخليه
والصحه ارياد درعي من منصبه جاء ذلك خلال
الجلسه الاسبوعيه للحكومه تنفيذا لقرار
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه وكانت المحكمه
قررت ان درعي ليس مؤهلا لتولي حقيبه
وزاريه بسبب ادانته مرتين بتهمه الاحتلال
الضريبي والسرقه في ذلك في ظل استمرار
المظاهرات الاسبوعيه تمديدا بسياساتها
حكومتي نتنياه
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه المتطرفه
نتنياهو لاهم حلفائه فيها زعيم حركه شخص
للمتدينين الشرطيين الزمته بها المحكمه
العليا وقد ابلغه في رساله الرسميه انه
مضطر لذلك لكنه سيبحث عن سبيل قانوني يتيح
عودته وكانت المحكمه قد قررت ان درع
المدانه بقضايا التحايل الضريبي والسرقه
ليس مؤهلا لتولي منصب وزاري
اذا وصلت الحكومه
من الكواليس فما جرى له لا يؤثر على بنيه
الحكومه
قضيه درعي جزء من الازمه المتفاعله في
اسرائيل سياسيا وشعبيا بسبب نتنياهو
وحكومته وما يسمونها الاصلاحات القضائيه
[موسيقى]
وعلى اساس تلك الحقائق مثل وجود رئيس
حكومه متهم جنائيا وعناصره داخل حكومته
تريد الاضرار بحقوق المواطن والانسان
نقوله هناك امر خلافي
واشد ما يقلقهم هو سعي الحكومه الى سن
قانون التغلب الذي يتيح للاغلبيه
البرلمانيه الغاء قرارات المحاكم والسيطره
على تعيين القضاه وهو ما دفع حركه جوده
الحكم ونقبا مختلفه واحزاب المعارضه الى
تنظيم سلسله من المظاهرات على امل قطع
الطريق امامه هذا المشروع
عشرات الالف يتظاهرون اسبوعيا في ميادين
المدن الكبرى خشيه ان يعين المتهمون
القضاه وهم ينظرون بغيبه الى ما سببه
احتلالهم للفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
الفصل العنصريه لقد نسينا الفاصله
العنصريه في المناطق الفلسطينيه وهو كما
يبدو يرتد علينا الان
[موسيقى]
ويؤكد المحتجون ان حركهم سيتواصلوا
وستزدادوا وزيرته من اسبوع الى اخر اريد
العمري الجزيره القدس الغربيه
السياسيه في الجامعه المفتوحه في حيفا
دكتور سليم اهلا بك في الحصاد هل نعتبر ما
حدث اليوم هو اول
ربما تهديد لائتلاف نتنياهو الحكومي وهل
هو بمثابه هروب الى الامام من جانب
نتنياهو هل يصح التوصيل لذلك
نعم اليوم طبعا كان انشقاق في حكومه
تتناول فيه اتجاهين الاتجاه الاول هو امام
المستوطنين طبعا في قضيه اخلاء البؤره
الاستيطانيه وهل هذا يعني هذا الموضوع لم
ينتهي بعد هناك ازمه والموضوع الثاني طبعا
هو ااا ان نتنياهو اضطري لقاله درعي لكي
يغير القوانين ويعيد ان يضرعي بطريقه اخرى
همم نتناه كان مضطر ليس رغبه منه بتنفيذ
قانون او قرار المحكمه كان يجب ان يقيله
من يومه الجمعه الاخير وليس الان اولا
وثانيا كان يجب ان لا يصل الى جلسه
الحكومه حاليا ولكن في نهايه المطاف
نتنياهو على اقل شكليا قام بهذا همم العمل
ولكن هناك من نتنياهو يطالب ان يكون همم
الرئيس الحكومه البديل وعلى هذا الاساس هو
يستطيع ان يكون حسب القانون الحالي بينما
نتنياهو يعارض هذا الموضوع لان هذا قد ما
كانت نتنيه او في المستقبل من ناحيه قدرته
على الاستمرار كرئيس حكومه من الناحيه
القضائيه طيب دكتور سليم همم في النهايه
قضيه درع هذه قضيه ولكن كما ذكرت الازمه
كبيره المظاهرات مستمره مستمره للاسبوع
الثالث على التوالي الى اي حد فعلا تؤثر
على حكومه نتنياهو
اولا ايه يعني
التظاهرات التي حدثت خصوصا بالامس هي غير
مسبوقه من سنوات الثمانين لم تكن هناك
ثورات بهذا بهذه النسب وهذه الاعداد
الكبيره وبعده اماكن التل ابيب السبع حيفا
واماكن اخرى المجتمع المدني في اسرائيل
القوي جدا وهو ااه مصر يعني ما يسمى دوله
تل ابيب هو مصر على ان الحكومه لا تستطيع
ان تغير قوانين الاساس ولا تستطيع ان تغير
تركيبه المحكمه العليا وان تخضع عن
المحكمه العليا للحكومه الكنيسه خاضعه
بشكل مطلق للحكومه رئيس الحكومه هو الذي
يعين رئيس الكنيست والرؤساء اللجان الهامه
ولذلك نحن نرى ان الكنيسه لا تعارض رئيس
الحكومه الان في كل ما يقوم به وهو عمليا
يقوم بهدم سلطه القانون في اسرائيل لان
هذا الطريق الوحيد هذا السبيل الوحيد
لاخراج نفسه من همم المحاكمه واربما ايضا
في السجن في المستقبل فاذا نتنياهو موجود
في خطر وهذا خطر ويهدد من هذه الناحيه ولا
ما يحدث الان نحن نرى فعلا الضغط شديد
نعم ولذلك نحن نرى انه يتحدث بطريقتين
مثلا هو وعد الامريكيين بان كل التغييرات
القانونيه ستكون بموافقه وباجماع واسع جدا
في المجتمع الاسرائيلي ولكن بنفس الوقت هو
تحدث الى زعماء للتلاف اليوم في اجتماع
زعماء الاتلاف وقال ان اهم شيء هو تمرير
هذه الاصلاحات او ما يسميها اصلاحات كما
هي تماما وباسرع وقت اي انه نتنياه يتحدث
الى الجميع لكل واحد باللغه التي يريد ان
يسمعها وهو عمليا همم
ينفذ طريقه اسلوبه في تغيير مبنى القضاء
في اسرائيل لكي يخدموا شخصيا ويخدم درعا
شخصيا الذي دعامه في الانتخابات الاخيره
ومن يراقب هذا اكيد عن كتب المعارضه الى
اي درجه المعارضه فعلا تستفيد من كل ما
يجري سواء على سعيد المظاهرات او التحديات
التي تواجهها الحكومه في الاقالات
نقطه القوه هذه الحكومه هي المعارضه
المعارضه مفككه في اسرائيل
لم يحدث
التظاهره في الاسبوع الماضي في الامس كان
10 دقائق فقط هذه المظاهرات تطالب بان لا
يكون هناك خطابات السياسيين وهذا ايضا
يضعف هذه التحركات لانه في نهايه المطاف
يجب ان يكون هناك رجال سياسه مخضرمين
يقومون بوضع الاهداف التي يجب الوصول
اليها من خلال هذا العمل او الميداني ولكن
نحن نرى خلافات في قلب المعارضه عدم همم
اتفاق حول استراتيجيات كيف سنواجه بنيامين
نتنياهو هناك من يتحدث عن ضروره ربما حوار
بين رجال نتنياهو والمعارضه ولكن ال- ال-
الشيء الفارق هنا والمثير الاهتمام هو صمت
رئيس الدوله يعني في هذه الازمه التي تعصف
بكل دوله اسرائيل نرى ان رئيس
تقريبا غير موجود على الساحه وهذا يدل على
عمق الازمه وعلى همم اسلوب نتنياهو يفسر
كضعف من قبل رئيس الدوله اولا وثانيا بان
لا يوجد اجماع في المعارضه في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي يعني هناك من يرى ان ال- ال-
الصراع امام هذه الحكومه يجب ان يكون في
البرلمان وهناك من يكون انه يجب ان يكون
في الساحات هناك من يقول انه يجب عدم همم
الدخول الى اي مفاوضات مع وزير القضاء
الاسرائيلي الذي هو عمليا وزير القضاء على
القضاء وليس وزير القضاء الذي اتى فعلا لا
يقوم باصلاحات وعلى هذا الموضوع هناك
خلافات حاده بين اعضاء الكنيسه وجعماء
المعارضه في الكنيسه شكرا
اتجاه الاخر للحديث عن الحكومه
الاسرائيليه طالب وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيليه ماهر بن جرير رئيس الحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو باخلاء وهدم تجمع الخان
الاحمر شرقي القدس المحتله وقالت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه انفير استعرب امام جلسه
الحكومه الاسبوعيه ما وصفه بالبناء غير
المرخص للفلسطينيين في المناطق المصنفه
جيم في خمسه مواقع وطلب باخلاء ردا على
اخلاق بؤره الاستيطانيه اقامها المستوطنين
يوم الجمعه الماضي
كسار الذي تقول
عن تطبيق القانون لكن لا يكون هناك قانون
للعرب واخروا لليهود وعند تطبيق قانوني
ينبغي تطبيقه ايضا في الخان الاحمر وعلى
عشرات البؤر غير قانونيه التي يقيمها
العرب القانون هو القانون
روحي فتوح مما وصفها بنكبه جديده بحق
الفلسطينيين في حال اقدام حكومه الاحتلال
على تنفيذي مخططها للاستيلاء على تجمع
الخانه الاحمر البدوي ويترقب سكان تجمع
الخانه الاحمر البدوي قراره سلطات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي النهائي والمتوقع
مطلع الشهر المقبل لتهجيرهم من التجمع
تلبيه لرغبتهم منظمه
الصهيونيه المتطرفه الساعيه لتفسير الارض
الفلسطينيه
بعد نحوي اربع سنوات ونصف من اصدار قرار
الهدم الذي توقف لاسباب سياسيه وضغوط
دوليه على حكومه الاحتلال في حينه تتحول
الانظار مجددا الى قضيه تجمع الخان الاحمر
البدوي شرقي القدس المحتله
يترقب سكان المخيم القرار النهائيه لمحكمه
الاسرائيليه الشهر المقبل بشان تنفيذ
الهضمي من عدمه
السكان وهنا يؤكدونا ان لا شيء سيثنيهم عن
التصدي لاي محاولات لاقتلاعهم من ارضهم
اذا لا سمح الله قدرنا هذه الاراضي سيتم
بناء المستوطنين في مكان هنا في ارضي في
مكان بيتي لن اغادر هذه حتى لو هدومه
وتمتد اراضي تجمع الخان الاحمر على مساحه
80 دولار شرقيه القدس المحتله ويترامى في
محيطه اكثر من 20 تجمعا بدويا و به خمس
صوتنات اسرائيليه
يعيش في التجمع نحو 240 شخصا له ويضم
مدرسه ومركز طبيا يخدمان خمسه تجمعات اخرى
الموقع الاستراتيجي للتجمع دفع منظمه
ريكاديمي الصهيونيه المتطرفه الى التحريض
بكل الوسائل على الاصلاح في تنفيذ قرار
هدم التجمع لتحقيق مشروع اي وان الخاص
بمخطط القدس الكبرى من خلال اختلاع
الفلسطينيين من اراضيهم وربط المستوطنات
بحزام المتواصل شرقيه المدينه
الجانب الرسمي الفلسطيني مع المؤسسات
الحقوقيه ومنها الاسرائيليه يعمل بكل جهد
للدفع باتجاه تحريك الملف في المحافل
الدوليه لمنع منظومه الاحتلال من تنفيذ
جرائمها
المنظومه هي منظومه التاسعه همم من اجل
تحقيق سياده يهوديه مطلقه على جميع
المنطقه وخاصه في المنطقه سي واستهدف
الوجود الفلسطيني
اول قبل الحكومات ولكن ممكن يقول يوم يكون
في هناك عمليه تسريع لهذه العمليه سكانها
هذا التجمع البدوي على موعد مع اخطر قرار
اسرائيلي لتهجيرهم قصرا تلبيه لرغبات
منظومه يمنيه متطرفه سياسيه وامنيا قرار
يتجاهل كل المواقف الدوليه من اجل ضمن
المنطقه الى ما يعرف
بمشروع القدس الكبرى
سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره من تجمع الخان
الاحمر البدوي شرقيه القدس المحتله
[موسيقى]
طلبت السلطات في بوركينا فاسو من فرنسا
بشكل رسمي سحب قوتها من البلاد في غضون
شهر في ذلك بعد المظاهرات مستمره منذ اشهر
للمطالبه برحيل الجنود الفرنسيين المتمر
[موسيقى]
لمساعده البلاد في مواجهه الهجمات
الارهابيه
وبالتواطئ في بعض الاحيان وقالت مصادره
قريبه من الحكومه الى القرار يتعلق
باتفاقات التعاون العسكري مع باريس
اما الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون فقال
انه سينتظر سيصدر رسميا عن رئيس المرحله
الانتقاليه في بوركينا فاسو بخصوص مطالب
ببلاده بسحب القوه الفرنسيه من هناك ولمحه
خلال مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع المستشار
الالماني الى وجوده على علاقه لروسيا بهذا
الموضوع
من التحدث فهمت ان الرسائل التي تم
تداولها في هذا الشان طويل على غموض كبير
هو موجود خارج العاصمه اعتقد انه يجب
الحذر الشديد والانتباه الى ان هناك من
تخصصات في المنطقه
في اوكرانيا واعني هنا اصدقاء الروس في
التلاعبات اذا سننتظر توضيحات من السيد
تراوري في هذا الاطار
ذكر طبعا المزاج الشعبي الرافض للنفوذ
الفرنسي تساعد خلال السنتين الاخيرتين
تحديدا ليس في بوركينا فاسو فحص بل في دول
اخرى غربيه افريقيا
وجاء متناهيا مع توجهاته النخب العسكريه
الجديده التي تحكم الدول
توجهات وضعت او بالاحرى وضعت على المحك
التحالفات التقليديه لفريس مع مستعمراتها
السابقه التي بدات تميل بوضوح للتعاون مع
حلفاء الجدد في مقدمتهام روسيا
خلال عامين فقط هزت سته انقلابات عسكريه
منطقه الساحل والصحراء في غرب افريقيا
ووقعت في كل من مالي وبوركينا فاسو وغينيا
واتشاد القاسم المشترك لهذه الدول انها
تشكل تحالفات عسكريه وسياسيه مع فرنسا
التي ظلت المنطقه على مدى عقود ضمن دائره
نفوذها في القاره
بلغ الوجود العسكري الفرنسي في دول الساحل
والصحراء ذروته عام 2013 بانتشار نحو خمسه
الاف 5500 جندي في مالي والنيجر تشاد ضمن
قوه بارخان لمحاربه المتمردين التواريخ في
شمال مالي وبنظره شامله لخريطه انتشار
القوات الفرنسيه في غرب افريقيا نجد
قاعدتين دائما عاصمه النيجر ووحده
المقاتله في المنطقه الحدوديه بين مالي
وبوركينا فاسو النيجر الى جانب قاعده جويه
فوار توجد قاعده عسكريه بها 9 يا عسكريه
بينما ينتشر 400 جندي من القوات الخاصه في
بوركينا فاسو
ترافقت انقلابته العسكريه خلال السنتين
الماضيتين مع مظاهرات شعبيه في مالي
وبوركينا فاسو وتشاد وغينيا تطالب بالحد
من النفوذ الفرنسيه وكان ذلك خيارا لقب
العسكريه الجديده في الحكم
فقد اتهم قاده الانقلاب في مالي فرنسا
بارتكاب ما سموها اعمالا عدوانيه تتمثل في
انتهاك سياده مالي ودعم من وصفوها
بالجماعات الجهاديه والتجسس على السلطات
في باماكو وفي اكتوبر عام 2021 انسحبت
القوات الفرنسيه من مدن كيدال وتساليت في
شمال مالي وافسحت المجال لمرتزقه فاجنر
الروسيه
ضمن نزوع من القياده العسكريه لتوثيق
التعاون مع روسيا
وبحلول منتصف اغسطس من السنه الماضيه
اعلنت باريس مغادره اخر كتيبه من قوه خان
الاراضي الماليه وقالت انها تعد
استراتيجيه عسكريه جديده في افريقيا
بالتشاور مع شركائها في القاره
تمهيد لذلك خفضت فرنسا تعداد قواتها في
منطقه الساحل بحلول نهايه العام 2022 الى
2,500 عسكري وقال الرئيس مانويل ماكرون ان
باريسه تطور مع حلفائها وضع القواعد
العسكريه الفرنسيه الحاليه وشكلها
ومهماتها في منطقه الساحل وغرب افريقيا
[موسيقى]
الى الصومال الان في عقابه هجوم لحركه
الشباب على مقر بلديه العاصمه مقديشو
اعلنت السلطات الصوماليه السيطره على
الوضع وانتهاء العمليه بعد تمكنها من
القضاء على جميع المهاجمين السته وقالت
وزاره الاعلام الصوماليه ان الهجوم اسفر
عن مقتل خمسه مدنيين
واصابه اربعه اخرين
تاخذي شويه وتستفيقوا من جديد على وقع
الهجمات بلديه العاصمه هي الهدف هذه المره
تفجيرات مباغته لها اقتحام مسلح حركه
الشباب لمقر البلديه حيث دارت مواجهات مع
الاجهزه الامنيه استمرت لاكثر من ست ساعات
وقد سددوا عروض وقلق بين مرتدي سوق
حمروينه حيث يقع مقر
البلديهم وتجاريه مفتوحه وكمارون السوق
كلهم يغلقون بسبب الوضع نسال الله السلامه
متحدث باسمها اعلنت مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم
وبعد ساعات من المواجهات اعلنت الحكومه
انهاء العمليه وانها قتلت عددا من
المهاجمين ما حدث اثار تساؤلات عن قدره
مسلح حركه شباب على الوصول الى مكان يقع
وسط المدينه
همم العائله
الطبيعيه ان تهاجم الحركه ومقرات الحكومه
لكن الجديره بالتساؤل هو لماذا لم تضع
الحكومه الاستراتيجيه لمواجهه الحركه ولم
توازن بين الحمله العسكريه خارج العاصمه
واتخاذ خطوات احتياطيه داخل المدينه
لتفادي مثل هذه العمليات الوص
ول الى كيلو تحديا للحكومه واجهزه الامن
التي تقود حربا ضد الحركه خارج العاصمه
معركه او صعو مواجهات مباشره تدور رحاحها
على اكثر من محور في الاقاليم الصوماليه
الوسطى بين القوات الحكوميه ومسلح حركه
الشبه خسره الحركه مواقع ومدنا رئيسها كان
اخرها مدينه حراري وسط الصومال ورغم
انحسار نفوذ الحركه في كثير من المحاور
فان هجماتها المباغته في مقديشها او في
المعقل التي خسرتها تبقى معضله كبرى لدى
الحكومه التي تسابق الزمن لكسب المعركه
والحفاظ على زخم التعاطف معها محليا
ودوليا الجزيره
[موسيقى]
اعلنت نائبه رئيس الوزراء الروسي فيكتوريا
اوبرا ماتشينكو انا روسيا تناقش استخدام
العمله الروسيه الروبل في تجاره الغذاء مع
مصر بعد نجاحها مع تركيا
بعد اعلان روسيا ادراج الجنيه المصري ضد
قائمتي عملاء عملاتها القابله للصرف وقال
خبراء مصريون ان القرار يعني سدد قيمه
الواردات الروسيه بالروبل خاصه القمح الذي
تعد روسيا المصدر الرئيس
يتعاملون بالجنيه المصري بدلا من الدولار
ويقدر حجمه التبادل التجاري بين البلدين
في نحو عشره مليارات دولار حاليا
ورغم محاولاتي تبديل بعملات اخرى لا يزال
الدولار الامريكي مهيمنا على النظام
المالي العالمي نظرا لعده عوامل يتدخل
فيها الاقتصادي السياسي
فاكثر من 60% من الاحتياطيات النقديه في
العالم هي في بالعمله الامريكيه كما ان
نحو 40 دوله تربط عملتها بالدولار
الامريكيه او تعتمده عمله تداولا رسميه في
عام 2016 نجحت الصين عبر مفاوضات مع صندوق
النقد الدولي في جعل عملتها اليوان ممثله
في الاحتياطيات العالميه من النقد الاجنبي
كما انشات في شن هاي بورصه عالميه لتداول
عقود النفط بالوان
اما جهود روسيا ضد دوله هذه الكلمه سببها
بين قوسين فبلغت ذروتها في مارس الماضي
اثر العقوبات الامريكيه والاوروبيه عليها
اقرر الرئيس بوتن تسعير صادرات بلاده من
النفط والغاز بالروبل بدلا من الدولار
اليوم
في يناير 2013 تعزيزا لتلك الخطوه اضافه
البنك المركزي الروسي قبل ايام الى سلته
المعتمده مقابل الروبل 9 عملات اجنبيه
جديده لكل من مصر والامارات
وقطر ونيوزيلندا تايلاند وفيتنام
واندنيسيا وصربيا وجورجه
ان تكون عمله ما معتمده ماذا يعني يعني ان
ان تستطيع الدول المتعامله مع ذلك البلد
الدفع بعملته وهو ما يستوجب توفر مبالغ
كبيره منها في البنوك المركزيه لتلك الدول
كجزء من احتياطياتها النقديه لكن هل من
فائده حقيقيه للاستغناء عن الدولار في ضوء
تغلغه في مفاصل الاقتصاد العالمي
بفعل قرار موسكو تدوي لعملتها في التجاره
الدوليه لاسيما النفط والغاز استقطار روبل
ان يتعافى وان يصبح العمله الافضل اداءا
في العالم وذلك خلال عام 2022 ليصل الى
نحو
60.55 روبل لكل دولار
كما تحاول روسيا التقليل من اثر العقوبات
الغربيه عبر تسهيل حركه صادراتها ووالدتها
وتسويه معاملاتها تجاريه مع باقي دول
العالم بعيدا عن الورقه الخضراء
في الصين مثلا اصبح اليوان رابع عمله على
مستوى العالم منذ انضمامه الى سله العملات
الدوليه حيث يشكل اليوم نحو ثلاثه في
المئه من اجماليه احتياطيه النقد الاجنبيه
العالميه بعد ان كان نحو واحد في المئه
فقط قبل عام 2016
اذا الان سنناقش كل هذه
التطورات وما تصب اليه روسيا معنا من
واشنطن ضيفنا شريف عثمان الخبير الاقتصادي
المصري سيد شريف اهلا وسهلا بك اذا
لنبدا يعني نحن في الواقع نريد نناقش هذه
الخطوه وعلاقتها بالجنيه المصري كيف
سيتاثر الاقتصاد المصري بهذه الخطوه برايك
اعتقد ان التاثير على الجنيه المصري سيكون
محدودا للغايه هذه الخطوه لا تعني في
الواقع العملي اي شيء لا توجد اي علاقه
تربط العمله المصريه بالروبل الروسي بصوره
مباشره الا من خلال الدولار وسعر الجنيه
المصري مقابل الروبيه
مقابل الدولار والجنيه مقابل الدولار
وبالتالي فان اي محاولات
الايحاء بان هذه الخطوه قد تساعد اي من
العمليتين الروسيه او المصريه هي يعني
مجرد اعتقد انها دعايه تساعد بالاساس همم
بصوره معنويه
البلديه ولكن في الواقع العملي لا يوجد اي
تاثير ولا يوجد اي مصادر لمصر
تاتي لها بالهبل همم بعيدا عن الدولار الا
من خلال الصادرات المصريه والسياحه
وهما العاملان الوحيدان اللذان يمكن ان
يساعد الجنيه المصري في علاقته
بالروبل كما بعلاقته لكل العملات الاخرى
وبالتالي يعني اعتقد ان التاثير محدود ولن
تكون هناك اي اضافه
وربما يكون السبب الاكبر الذي تلجا اليه
روسيا حاليا في طلبها الحصول على قيمه
صدرتها
بالروبن هو الابتعاد عن العقوبات الغربيه
رقيه كانت او امريكيه همم يعني كل مدفوعات
الدولار واليورو تمر عبر البنوك الغربي
التي فرضت همم عقوبات اقتصاديه كبيره على
روسيا وقد يعني تجمد بعض تلك الارصده
عليها
الابتعاد عن هذه المشكله
الولايات المتحده كيف يعني تتابع هذه
الخطوات همم هل لديها تحفظات او اعتراضات
وما واجه
لا شيء على الاطلاق لا يذكر الخبر في اي
من وسائل الاعلام او تتم مناقشته بصوره
جلديه همم يعني مجرد الحصول على مقابل
الصادرات بالرجل الروسي لا يعطي حتى
العمله الروسيه اي دفعه فكل التعاملات كما
قلت يعني تاتي من خلال العلاقه بالدولار
ربما ما يمكن توفيره في هذه الخطوه هو بعض
العمولات التي تحصل عليها البنوك لو ارادت
مصر همم تحويل ما لديها من دولار الى
روبيل او العكس في روسيا وبالتالي يعني
هذه العملات عاده لا تتجاوز واحد بالمئه
همم في الظروف المعتاده همم يعني الامر لا
يؤخذ بجديه هنا في الولايات المتحده ربما
يكون التركيز مع الصين بحجم التعاملات
الكبير وهمم التاثير الذي يمكن ان يحدث لو
تطلقت او كانت هناك محاولات لتدوير
العملاتها او لتحل محل الدولار او اليورو
لكن هذا الامر حتى مستعد خلال على الاقل
10 سنوات من الان ولا يوجد اي تولد تقول
استاذ شريف انها لا تاخذ بجديه هذه
الخطوات ولكن ماذا عن وضع الروبل يعني قبل
قليل استعراضنا الروبل وصل الى اقوى
مراحله خلال العام الماضي رغم كل ما يجري
رغم كل العقوبات المفروضه على روسيا وهمم
المحاولات للسيطره على كبار رجال الاعمال
فيها وايقافهم عن العمل رغم هذا الروبل
القوي وربما اقوى من اي وقت المباراه
قوه العمله تتحدث بالاساس كاي سلعه اخرى
بالطلب عليها والمعروض منها ولد طلب على
الرجل الروسي في الفتره الاخيره او
السنوات الاخيره كان يعني كبيرا بسبب انها
تصدر الغاز والنفط وبالتالي وايضا الحبوب
وايضا خلال العام الاخير ارتفاعات كبيره
في اسعار هذه السلعه وبالتالي كان هناك
قائد كبير في الحساب الجاري الجاري الروسي
وهو ما يدعم قوه العمله لكن مع التسليم
بان الامور الطبيعيه كانت تؤدي الى قوه
العمله الروسيه بسبب ارتفاع اسعار
الصادرات الروسيه الا انه يجب ان ياخذ في
الاعتبار ايضا ان النظام سعر الصرف المتبع
في روسيا ليس حرا كما يحدث في الدول
الاوروبيه او في اليابان او سويسرا مثلا
وبالتالي يعني لا يمكن الحكم على هذه
التطورات في قيمه العمله بصوره سليمه لان
انا لا نعرف ما تجري عليه الامور في البنك
المركزي الروسي ولكن كما قلت ان قوه ال-
ال- الصادرات الروسيه وارتفاع ثمنها هي
التي ادت الى قوه العمله بشكل كبير او
بررت تقويه البنك المركزي لعملته خلال
العام الاخير
همم
عثمان الخبير الاقتصادي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
فينما ننهي الحصاد هذه الليله نتوقف عند
قصه الخان الاحمر التي كانت معنا قبل قليل
وهي قصه نضال لا تكره بالبرد او الحر او
محاولات لا تتوقف
لاقتلاعهم من ارضهم من خيام وبيوت من صفيح
يرون ان البقاء جزء من الرساله رساله
النضال ورسم الاحتلال
انتهى الحصاد شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]